foreign
[Applause]
world channel provides an audio
augmented reality experience to enable
you to understand and explore your
environment you'll be able to hear
people and things in the room announced
from their 3D position for example the
word chair coming from the chair this
requires that you wear headphones but
make sure to choose headphones which do
not block out external Sounds here we
have the seeing AI app open with the
voiceover screen reader running we can
swipe over to the channel switcher and
up to the world channel channel short
text adjust document product person
currency scene World preview
the features we discussed in this video
are only available on a device with a
lighter as I swipe around with here two
buttons filters button filters which
provides customization for what is
announced actions button and actions
which contains a menu of different tools
which we'll discuss in a moment as they
Pan the phone around the room I hear
objects being announced as they come
into view
share
cup book because I'm wearing headphones
I hear the sounds coming from the 3D
location door
so I can tell that the door is further
away to the right
plant
share
while there are some plants and chairs
nearby on the left
person we just heard seeing air I say
person so I know there's someone over to
the right
arita I recognize your voice now
wouldn't it be cool if seeing AI had
actually identified who it was rather
than saying the word person let's swipe
over to the actions button actions
button
recognizable people button I can now ask
Rita to take three selfies to teach
seeing AI to recognize her recognize new
person one face near Center less than a
meter away as we swipe through the
screen we hear there is one recognizable
person recognizable people reader button
let's go back to the main screen and
when Rita is recognized we'll hear how
her name is now spoken Rita
let's take a quick look at the filters
button filters button
filters as we swipe through we see there
are three filters announced objects
announce people
we can select have people or objects
announced we can also choose to have
proximity reported proximity sensor if I
turn this on on I will feel my phone
vibrate as things are closer the
vibration gets more intense and if I
point it say at the door suddenly when I
come across the opening it gets much
fainter
finally let's take a look at placing a
beacon let's go over to the actions menu
action the top item here spatial summary
will let me hear all the things which
have been detected but I want the next
one place Beacon glaze vegan this shows
me a list of everything that's been
detected in the room so far
I'm going to select the door door three
meters front I hear a beacon sound in my
headphones and visually we see an arrow
pointing towards the door and a label
showing the distance three meters as I
move towards the door the distance goes
down and I can hear the beacon getting
remember you have to look in the
direction of the camera 2.4 meters As
you move the camera left and right we'll
hear the sound move according to two
meters and as we reach the door we hear
this nice little successor to indicate
we reach there and sure enough we could
walk straight through the door without
touching the sides
while we were doing that it was
important to look in the direction of
the camera
however if you're using headphones which
supports spatial audio we can keep the
sound coming from the correct location
regardless of which way you're looking
let's swap out for a pair of airpods and
turn on the transparency mode so we
still hear the sound in the room as soon
as we put the headphones in seeing AI
prompted me to calibrate
alert calibrate headphones this is so
that it knows which direction I'm
looking in I just look straight at the
phone and tap continue okay
headphones calibrated now as an example
if I place a beacon on the door and look
left and right while the camera stays
still I'm gonna hear the sound always
coming from the door regardless which
way I look
so that's a brief overview of the world
Channel and the idea of audio augmented
reality
seeing AI observes the world around you
and recognizes things in 3D it provides
a variety of tools such as placing a
beacon to help you interact with the
world